Dominic Wilcox is working in the way he
likes best getting away from it all in
the great outdoors where he can think
and sketch out his ideas and that's made
all the easier with his portable three
discs it's just one of Wilcox's
wonderful inventions in London st.
John's Museum you can see his latest
creation a ghetto blaster that you can
power up with a live stand or a light
fitting Wilcox got the idea from an
exhibition project for artists were
commissioned to design for objects by
means of a process akin to Chinese
whispers the first artist was given a
stethoscope as his source of inspiration
the result was this lamp Lou Cox was
next up
and I was given this light and I didn't
know who designed it or what i just
opened the box and the light was in it
and i had to find inspiration from that
to create my object so i took the simple
idea that it was a ceiling light and i
thought about why do we just put light
bulbs in ceiling light sockets you know
you could put a television a microwave a
toaster and screw it into the soccer but
really my idea was to put some music
into the living room and into the light
socket a radio swinging from the ceiling
the next big thing one of the curators
says commercial success is not the point
I'm going to be mass produce but it's
going to massively influence all the
designers would do product as i right oh
really no that's that's weird finally
it's not so weird I can see it if I was
an interior designer doing a bar for
example in a hotel when you want to
bring a bit of fun in it you could
easily put that in this kind of public
more public spaces and that will bring
something very very interesting when
directly bringing my smile on your on
your face that's true of most things
Wilcox makes he gets his inspiration on
the street or in cafes whether or not
his designs can be put to practical use
is not his concern I'm really interested
in in the concept in the idea in the
imagination so if it exists in someone's
mind you know that's you know for me
i'll create something it will tell a
story and once that story is told it
lives in the mind you know for hopefully
a long time and that's fine by me
Dominic Wilcox places well-known
everyday objects in new context to
create a fresh perspective on the
seemingly ordinary so how should we
classify his work is he an artist a
designer and inventor in a world between
art design craft and invention being an
inventor so I'm just doing my own thing
really you know I'm just interested in
creativity in innovation and finding
surprises these customized shoes
precisely unite this combination of
qualities he designed them for a large
English company they can even put their
we're on the right track
the first thought I had was to think
about Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz and
dorothy was some ruby red slippers and
when she clicked the heels together she
was taken home to Kansas little magic
shoes and I thought is it possible to
recreate these shoes in some way giving
modern technology he equipped the shoes
with a complete GPS system
once you've set your destination the
light diodes incorporated into the shoes
point you in the right direction all the
way to Kansas if you wish quite
practical you might think or maybe just
outright ridiculous it's important to
think the ridiculous until you know to
write it down to draw it out because the
ridiculous idea what seems ridiculous
can lead you into new directions that
haven't been thought of before so
sometimes I'll come up with ideas that I
think I'm not so sure about that idea
but I'll draw it but then it will
trigger another idea and another ID and
eventually you get to a place which is
far away from the original starting
point and it's far more interesting even
if it's maybe not always clear where his
left field ideas are going they're
always worth a second look the eclectic
inventions of Dominic Wilcox
you